because jvp was losing he got a little
upset he grabbed
prince and dumped him in the cold tub
bro when i tell you he dumped him in the
cold tub it was like if prince was this
stick
jpp had that guy over his head like this
head first
[Music]
just tuck what's good with you baby i'm
all good boss all good how you doing
retired life man it's pretty decent word
on the street is you working weird now
this place called goldman sachs you know
some slight you know what i'm saying
you need some more clients like yeah i
do always how much more do i got to be
making
it's up there
so justin everybody says rappers want to
be ball players ball players want to be
rappers
how is hip-hop culture immersed when you
were playing in the giants
that statement is so true just in the
giants locker room along every day
we had rap battles well that was one
versus one
a whole cipher whatever it may be man
listen we did not care
anything was fair game other than like
obvious things right you don't talk
about people wives and kids but like
your divorce wife
she's fair game like one of the bigger
days in that kind of whole thing was
oc and stray it was kind of like a setup
where oc was like the young bull
trying to kick straight in out of being
the guy like michael strahan hall of
famers but osu was like he had just
signed his new deal
straight handed just got divorced
literally they set up this rap battle
with stray and oc strays just like yo
it's a rap battle whatever i showed
tomorrow and i'll i'll kick a few rhymes
and be done
oc took it so serious he went home that
day and literally was like writing down
rhymes like he was right now
i think he was testing against people
that you know his buddies and his
girlfriend all that like how this
sounded like because he come back the
next day
super confident how you gonna do it in
the cypher though oh she a cheater man
oh she cheats don't ever play him in
like fifa none of that
coming on the show so
osu came in cheating prepared with these
google lines that he did
how was straight hand coming so straight
had like one of those mariah carey like
golden mics
and he brings his golden mic he brought
it in in like a brown paper bag so he
also prepares a rhyme
and like the rhyme had everything in it
talking about his new deal how he's
making more money straight now how he's
kicking him out of the league
basically saying like his old wife
didn't want him so the giants don't want
him all that
we're like crying laughing i knew it was
going to go there because that's just
how it is we always went there but
straight was kind of cut off guard you
can see it in his face
because he had prepared so he gets up
bad and like he brings his old mic
out and just goes handle start spinning
start spitting
to stray his credit man straight is
witty man he's quick with it he gets up
there man he starts talking about
his deals and all the deals he signed
hall of fame talk about
his cars his houses he just broke the
lt's all-time sack record
of the giants and ended it by saying
like yeah i gave my
wife a free trip to disneyland gave her
a few dollars and she still got more
than you
basically he gave his ex-wife his chump
change and
that money is still more money than what
oc just signed for i think straight won
that one
because he was like off the cuff how did
everybody respond to
what it was epic everybody like gathered
around the door and heard this
it was like a epic scene of like people
like running down the halls like crying
laughing
i've never heard of a team
every week we did some stuff man i can't
share them true
untold stories of stuff but like that's
just what we did to become a tighter
group
jpp and trail roll what happened bro
don't quote me on this no i'm i think
they were
battling they were rap battles we had
this rookie named prince of nukamore
he was always trying to get in it so
instead of him just sitting back
every time antrell says homo jpp said
something he was that odd hype man and
be like
ooh because jvp was losing he got a
little upset
he grabbed prince and dumped him in the
cold tub
bro when i tell you he dumped me in the
cold tub it was like if prince was this
stick
jp had that guy over his head like this
head first of the culture
we're actually doing him a favor prince
leia is going to be refreshed when he
come out of here
i did not expect that out of a tom
coughlin team my whole perception is
cowboys fan was just i was living that
military lifestyle
i mean that was an obsession man but we
had fun though man we had to
now that's it right there y'all see the
hands good game man
oh i got in there
[Music]
yo i'm justin tuck do me a favor
subscribe to bleacher report
and check out untold stories